welcome to the presentation my name is
detron this is michael mcdonald oaks and
we are both their scientists at collapse
today we want to share our experiences
and best practices with pice part before
we is going to start with the
presentation is noted that this talk is
actually intended for people who have
already some kind of experience with pi
squared so we assume that you have some
kind of basically standing of Pi spark
or spark in general so this is the plan
for today first of all I will give a
short very short introduction into PI
spark then run on is going to talk about
data structure and giving some handy
tips for the creation and performances
then I will speak about unit testing
with PI sport and then I'll as well
about data pipeline management and then
we're gonna will give a small example
about online learning and with price
screaming and then I will give an
example how you can put your models into
protection so what is a pice book
basically pi spark is Spock API for
Python so how does it actually work
every time every time you start up ice
bucket vacation so in a masternode it
actually created a Python spark context
and then through the spark context it
actually used pie for J which is also in
python module to spark to start a job or
spa context and then the spa jabber
splash context actually connects to to
the spark workers on the remote working
machines the remoter work machines then
actually starts Python sub processes and
the communication happens through pipe
as you can see compared to scholar or to
each other that we also always
additional time because you have to
start the pisan subprocess doing the
high-spec application and also very
important note is in terms of the data
because data will be serialized in both
the JVM and the Python subprocess which
this will also cost additional
a time and another important point in
terms of this architecture is that the
Python memory isn't actually controlled
by the JVM so for example if you
probably have a very reasonable settings
in yarn or something this you you still
might get some kind of other memory
error but this is a topic that runner
will take them all yeah let's review
some of the data structures in iceberg
we have resilient distributed data sets
which everything else is build on these
are a fault-tolerant collection of items
and they support two types of operations
transformations and actions
transformations they are always lazy so
they're not so when you execute the
transformation these are not evaluated
immediately only when you perform an
action on these transformations and
another important notice that our dd's
are immutable and the the other
important data structure is our data
frames data frames are collections of
rows with a schema and for the most part
these are kept within the JVM so they
have a very large performance advantage
over the native / / using our dd's with
PI spark the notable exception here or
if you're using Python udfs and so you
should always use native functions
whenever possible and what data frames
do if you run these native operations on
them they take your pies and calls and
compile them down to native java
bytecode and because and because these
these data frames say they have metadata
about the types contained in them and so
on there you're able to run many more
optimizations on the enhancer
performance improvement and one one last
tip is you should always create data
frames with a hive context and not the
default civil context because you get
many more udfs you get window window
functions and so on so there's quite a
lot of advantages there and you don't
even need
I have installed to use the hive context
this is a benchmark of using Python data
frames as opposed to as opposed to I
mean spark data frames as opposed to our
dd's what you can see in this benchmark
is that they have the Python Python
spark data frames they have exactly the
same performance in this group by
reduced operation as a native Scala code
and this is because it boss used to
compile down to java bytecode whereas if
you're using our dd's there's a there's
a lot of performance degradation for
using python as opposed to the native
scala api and this happens because
there's serialization happens in two
places as that noted when the Python
process rights something to an RDD it is
serialized this pickle and when it reads
it again it's deserialized is pickle
again so this is a serialization happens
twice there and finally there's a new
day a new data structure in pious park
that came in 1.6 is a data set this is
not available in pais park yet only in
Java and Scala and it's statically typed
so limiting the space further of what
can be expressed enables even more
optimization similar to what is
available in a database so a query
optimizer is able to do much more with
this is actually data structure which is
taken from the Apache chief link project
and in spark to point all these two data
structures they will be unified like
they are in Apache fling now it's not
clear yet how these will be handled in
pais part because pythons of course not
a statically typed language so maybe a
bit awkward to handle but it will come
with a lot of performance advantages I'm
configuring spark is actually the most
difficult part in practice what we have
encountered so so first of all let's
have a look at the configuration
precedence there are three places in
pais park where you can set your
configuration first of all
programmatically within your
actual script using the spark on command
then you can pass configuration options
to the command line and finally you can
set all the options also in the spark
configuration files and they they have a
certain order of precedence so what you
said programmatically over always
overrides what you said in the command
line and what you said in your
configuration files such that such as d
state precedents and what you said in
the command like takes precedence over
what you said in your configuration
files spark memory management used to be
the most complicated part of running
spark so in spark one point in spark 1.5
and below there used to be two separate
manager memory managers for execution
memory and storage memory and this
caused a lot of problems execution
memory is where you compute shuffles
join and so on so so these sort of
things spill into execution memory where
whereas storage memory is used for
caching and distributing internal data
sources across across clusters and then
there is a user memory use a memory you
can use to store your own data
structures you can basically do do
whatever you want in the in the user
memory now in the big change that came
in spark 1.6 is that the boundary
between storage and execution memory
became dynamics so spark handle stress
boundary can shift this boundary and
this is a really really big advantage
because because in spark 1.5 it used to
be the case that if you four examples
that set your storage memory fraction to
1.5 to 0.5 but your execution memory was
temporarily larger it started spilling
to disk instead of taking the empty
storage memory right so for every single
spark script you ran you you actually
had to fiddle around which is a storage
memory fraction and this is gone and
spark 1.6 also configuration became much
much easier
but let's jump to a work work example
because in the docs tells you what each
option in PI spark means each
configuration option but when I read
this documentation I had absolutely no
idea what what I should actually set the
values to we have to start with yarn
config we have an example here with with
six nodes each have 16 cores and 64
megabytes 4 gigabytes of RAM each and
you have to leave some resources for the
OS and the due process is you would
approximately set your node manager
resources to about 61 gigabytes in this
example and you also have to leave one
core for the osu so you use about 15
course here and what you also have to do
is to get the most out of your cluster
and avoid network and iocp you wait you
should overcommit you should over commit
your resources by about a factor of 1.5
so on our example here we are using for
executors with six executors course each
on six nodes and that leaves you with a
executors memory of eleven thousand six
hundred megabytes for each for each node
and what is also important to note is
that the piping memories managed outside
of the JVM process so it comes on top of
this by default each passing process is
given 512 megabytes of RAM now and and
because we have 24 executors we have 24
of these processes and this is something
we have to take in mind and if you get
the python out of memory errors one
thing you can do is you can reduce the
concurrency so you can go down to for
example for executors per node and why
would you why would you want to do this
so for example what we have done in the
past
we've used up iceberg for example to
drive cross validation from scikit-learn
to paralyze it over a cluster right and
if you're starting to fit models within
pies Sparkie definitely you need more
than 512 megabytes of RAM so what
happens is you you start getting out of
memory errors and that's when you have
to reduce this concurrency and then
start increasing your spark passion
working memory and this leaves you with
with less executors memory but that's
that's how you can avoid these out of
memory errors some other useful settings
we have found is that you can save a
substantial memory in in in pais park by
turning compression on and if you run pi
spark in a cluster you should always
enable speculative execution speculative
execution means that if workers
particularly slow or fails spark will
automatically restart that task before
the other worker returns or fails or
returns an error or something so this
will speed up things a lot if you have
one slow worker in your cluster is
slowly starting to degrade something
we've really struggled with because
we're we exclusively work with Python 3
is there are many issues using Python 3
and in PI spark because in Python 3
there is a new security feature where
you use hash randomization to do provide
protection against denial of service
attacks now this means that in a cluster
environment a Python 3 will fail on
group by and reduce by key operations
and just exporting the pies expires in
the hash seat on the main on a main node
will not resolve this issue so if you
want to use Python 3 in a cluster
environment you have to set this setting
in your spark defaults conf otherwise
things will
go wrong and if you if you want to tune
performance there are several things to
keep in mind one thing is you should
always cash your RT DS you're going to
reuse so for example if you're if you
take a gander example of using
cross-validation the distributed among
your cluster you're going to use that
our DD many times during your
cross-validation either with Emily poor
scikit-learn so what you want to do is
cash that data before running
cross-validation otherwise your dd's
will keep being recomputed and it's
going to slow down things a lot another
thing is you should avoid group by key
whenever possible because this requires
all values for single key to fit into
memory and this will actually not happen
if you use a data frame group by key
because it uses this optimizers like in
a database and one thing I don't think
enough people know about yet is that you
can actually read distribute data by key
now since Park 1.6 is a really important
feature because because what what spark
used to do is randomly distribute data
by a by a hash and if you then run a
group by operation it needed to do a
shuffle and collect all the data of a
particular group in one node right but
if you have a use case for example if
you if you want to fit a 1 scikit-learn
model pair group say you your your
global company and you want to calculate
one churn model / country with
scikit-learn so you want to basically do
a group i and then map your psychic
learn model over this group data then
there would be a lot a lot of shuffles
on your cluster and things would go out
of memory or fail or something like that
and so what you can do now since Park
1.6 is you can actually if you know
ahead of time what key or you're going
to do this computation on you can
actually when you when you read in a
data frame or rdd you can
partition it and then already group it
by key when reading in the data such
that when you operate when you do this
operation there needs to be no shuffles
and that really really speeds up things
a lot and then to two things here always
prefer tree reduce and tree aggregate
over the standard reduce and aggregate
functions because these use more much
more intelligent binary tree algorithms
to to compute these aggregates by
computing intermediate results whereas
with the standard reduce function you
one node could become a huge bottleneck
and finally if you have look-up tables
you should always broadcast these or
small tables with frequently accessed
values because otherwise these keep
having to be shuffled around the cluster
now on to unit testing with PI spark so
before starting with this who have you
have a computer scientist background
well yeah it's not much but ok so let's
start with the situation that some of
you might know so there's a PhD student
with his professor he probably doesn't
have a computer science back row because
right so he says like you wrote a code
it's in elegant it's messy it's
inefficient and oh can you guys read
this so so it's nice like well i
finished the computer program I need it
for my research it's not pretty but it
worked it's in elegant messy inefficient
and if you try to change anything about
it it will probably explode and the
Prophet says well sounds like every
academic I've met great can I get my PG
know so do you know the situation right
so I mean mostly a scientist doesn't
have a computer scientist computer
science background so this is a
situation which is probably fine in
academia academia but in reality it can
be a little different difficult because
if you for example put your code into
production right you have a lot of code
and spending time on debugging
bucks is is quite problematic because if
you ever wrote a code that is that is
used in production you will know this
experience so what is this solution to
this well add piva laps we have a core
practice which is called TDD so it
stands for test-driven development and
what is actually TD well in the 2d you
actually start to write your tests first
and then you write as literally as code
as possible to have the test pass and
and then you just refactor your code so
this is actually tdv of course so so far
this has been a great benefits for our
17 years so we are pretty famous for
this kind of approach but surely the
reality can of course be difficult for
us right because we're not several
engineers most of us are data scientists
so in a sub engineer you probably might
like program app and in this app you
have a button and the button for example
is red right so writing a unit test for
a button that is red is much easier but
in it but in a data science contacts you
get a problem right and you're trying to
solve this problem with some different
models right and at first you don't know
which if this model is going to work so
there's a lot of iron d or uncertainty
or stochastic component involved in this
and that's why what we actually do is we
split it in a two phase so there is one
face which is called exploration phase
and the other phase is called the
production phase in the exploration
phase where we actually do is we use
iPads notebook and all of these things
to experiment with different models we
do cross validation something this and
but during this phase we also get to
know a lot of the models right and also
the output what you get so for example
let's say there's a use case there's a
company they want to rate the client
right so a typical approach which is
like to use clustering method for
example like k-means so and in K means
you actually what you do is you you
might need to transform your data you
rescale your data because K means what's
better in this way and then at the end
of the day you fit your data you glad
the cluster centers and
and you just use a function to to to
assign this to a labor right of course
you using ipython notebook is of course
not optimal for example you know yeah
that this rating works and it works well
and then you want to put your code into
production right because it should be
done automatically and that's why the
next step what we call is actually
called production phase so we're trying
to put everything that we've done in the
ipod notebook in a scrip and and here
actually starts to TDD approach so for
this in terms of pies work what we do
for testing is we're using a single note
spark application and if you want to
make us it's really easy to install it
so you just use proves the the spark
apps and then and then also what you can
see is we just assign it to one keyword
memory in just one core so it's a local
system and a very important point as
well as when we write a test we actually
mock the data so in a unit test the test
should be run pretty fast so that's why
we're not reading from a real database
this is actually how a test looks like
so relating to the clustering example
again I yeah usually you convert your
data frame right then you rescale your
data and then you're assigned to the
clusters and because we're mocking the
data we have some kind of understanding
of the data and the algorithm so
actually tgd forces you to think about
how the algorithm works right because
most most of the people just use model
and algorithm from our or any package
and then they just fitted so they never
try to understand what the meaning of
this algorithm is and what it does
actually so and it's G you you need to
think about this and then what you
actually do afterwards when you wrote
the test the test is probably failing
because there's no implementation right
so you start to write your
implementation and basically this is the
minimum viable code
you can write to to have the test pass
that Astro of course there are some
points that you can do like for example
k is to seduce one is something this you
can create global variables instead of
the variables instead in in within the
function so you still can do some
refactoring actually put a for example
how you would implement the clustering
examples so it's on my repo so you can
check it out later yeah another
important topic that I want to talk
today shortly is about data pipeline
management give a question is actually a
pipeline management so as well as you
might know so in a model or something
like this there are a lot of different
steps in world right so you reading from
a database and then you're fit in your
model and then you're predicting for
example in the classic example you might
read from a database and use a cigarette
script and in sequel you also do some
transformation and then in a Python
script you strain your model you
paralyzed this model right and then you
fit the model and you do cross
validation so doing all this step is
actually a sequential and depends and
there are some dependencies with it
within this and of course if you just
look at the clustering example it's
quite small but if you add more use
cases more and more when time goes by it
can become quite complex so what we did
actually in the past we wrote our own
pipeline a script in in Python so here
in this example we actually shamed
sequel and Python together one of the
disadvantages in this approach is when
you use Spock's MIT and and for example
that have it run through a cron job the
device the the sequel files and the
Python script have to do to be
distributed all the work notes just
imagine you have ten working machines
right you have to for example if you're
not smart enough justice SSH into all of
these machines and then uploaded or of
course you can also use like pssh dscp
to upload all the fights but this is
quite a hassle because every time you
change your code you have
upload it again and another important
point is of course you have to write
your custom loggers and we spent a fair
amount of writing our custom logging
information and if you're already dead
with the logging module it's quite
powerful that it's also quite very quite
time consuming that's why what we did is
we switch to luigi luigi is a pipeline
module which is developed by my spotify
it's one hundred percent python it comes
along with a web dashboard you have
parallel workers you can pass parameters
through it and it has many templates for
various tests like like like a spark
lexpark as well it is not as powerful as
air flow or something this but it
actually serves our purposes this is
actually an example how you would write
a task force box so you actually just
just import the spokesman task here in
this example i'm referring to the
clustering example again so i'm actually
defining some parameters like the number
of k which i just can pass in a cron job
and then i also added this additional
options and this is actually the pretty
cool thing so you can just specify your
dependencies in just one liner so in
this case the future engineering test
has to run first and then the clustering
test will run afterwards this is
actually what we also do so we usually
don't specify the configuration in in
programmatic anymore but we have a luigi
config file where we also specify
settings for Spock as well and with this
actually the architecture changed so in
this kind of approach we don't need to
to upload or dispute all your sequel and
Python fights anymore but you just run
it from the master node so it's in quite
much more convenient of course there are
some caveats you don't have a built-in
job trigger so we'll still have to use
cron job the decree nation could be
better logging is quite okay but when
you have multiple workers they could
cause a much hassle and if you have many
tasks that could be a problem with the
parameters because you have to pass all
of this as
onto onto a new feature of spark is
online earning with spice Park this is
actually something I want to point out
to you it's not it's not concrete how to
but lately we've experimented with using
sparks stream processing and online
learning capabilities of emilybs
stochastic gradient based descent based
methods to create a real-time machine
learning models which can update
themselves on new data in the stream as
it arrives and at the moment only
streaming linear regression and
streaming k-means is implemented but
many more models are coming in the
future there are they're quite
interesting use cases with this for
example what you can do is if you're
running an a/b tests you can actually
run multiple models within your spark
streaming context and evaluate this in
real time and for example using a
bayesian bandit approach try to optimize
these models in real time and always
only expose the optimal models to user
another another use case would be a
performance monitoring so for example if
performance suddenly starts to degrade
in your models you can send out an alert
and so on and third use case would be if
you if you're if you if if the data
generating process changes right so you
have the possibility that the model
adapts to that change very very quickly
as data streams in unlike in a batch
environment where maybe you compute a
new model every week or every day or
something like this and this sort of
setting you're able to adapt to changes
extremely quickly under the hood
Emma lip and streaming algorithms uses
for each our DD and map to make these
computations if you look at the source
code the implementation is actually
quite straightforward one downside with
spark streaming is that it operates on
mini batches that means it takes a chunk
of data and then does a computation so
essentially it's doing a batch operation
but only at certain fixed time steps so
it's not really a true streaming
framework that means in a distributed
setting you will never get better
latency than about one second so it's
not it's not it's not something you can
use for example as a predictive API if
you need a fast response in that regard
Apache chief linka is also a very
promising project because it can
evaluate these streams in real time and
it also has a very powerful similar
capabilities to spark but the problem is
that at the moment there is no good and
well documented sparkle sorry python api
for for link but there's also an
interesting project to watch in regards
to online learning and finally onto
operationalization we still three
minutes ok ok go for five minutes or so
yeah 3 minutes 2 minutes ok ok ok well
I'll make it quite fast ok so actually
it probably laughs we've ok yeah
basically this is but this is a very
important topic actually so at pivotal
f's we actually follow an API first
approach so we try to put every model
that we do in the Navy I and for doing
so we are using flash and flash who have
you have ever heard of flask ok cool so
you know what flashes right so flashes
of the light weighted web framework and
what we actually do here is we should
train our model and PI sport and then we
without a wee Pig early we on pickle
into we pick a little too too too like
for example a database like Redis or
hdfs like the file system of HMS and
then what we do is then we load the
model and afterwards we write our own
function to to to predict like in the
label in this case this is also very
fairly example so i usually a use post
to post some some data through Jason and
then from the JSON file i actually will
create a Perez airframe and then from
there I use to predict function within
with the model to return label in
reality the the output of the flash this
flash API is much much more complicated
right because here in this example you
wish to scat the label but for example
if you if you're in a prediction use
case or some like this you might get a
get a dictionary of probabilities and
some metadata along with this so but I
think with this example you probably get
the idea so as I said again we actually
use flash to create the API but of
course for deploying it you cannot use
work so I got something like this right
so for deploying we're actually using
cloud foundry have you ever heard of
clarity before ok ok three people so
it's not so flat ferntree is actually an
open source project and pivotal is also
one of one of the biggest committer it
is actually a platform as service if you
ever have deployed an API before it's
quite a hassle right because you have to
take care of the load balancing you have
to take care of routing or for example
if you're also change of your code red
you have to put it on the vm again and
something this so is there's a lot of
things and actually what with this quote
from one of our colleagues says is
here's my sauce coats run it on the club
for me I don't under how so this is
actually what what what California is is
doing for it for you actually we also
have a trial version so it's for two
months so check it out if you want to
use it and also one of my colleagues in
Houston you presented CF last year
potater there are some examples with
python and and CF
it's also worth checking this out okay
that's it time for questions thank you
very much are there any questions I have
two questions first why it's like at the
beginning you mentioned this data
structure so you compare the pace on a
DD sorry hi spike our DD and also
scholar yeah it's like a much slower
right yes so what's the advantage to you
surprised but I can start our scholars
back well Python is over we're at a
Python conference so we love we love
using Python and it's it's a it's also
an easier language to use so many people
in the PI data community they come from
having academic backgrounds or they
don't have a computer science background
and then not be necessarily comfortable
to use a statically typed programming
language like Scala and so they do use
they used to Python from from doing
computations on your local machine using
pandas using scikit-learn and so on and
so this is something much easier for
them and then getting into something
like Scala so the second question you
said that's a you try for a very
specific question like avoid to use the
reduce back here right so once you need
to use this because this is always the
problem is I tried so the if you really
need to use this the reduced by k I mean
you have to reduce them so what do you
do what's the typical strategy to avoid
it after so it's actually not reduce
battery by but but but group by key so
strategy to avoid it is a difficult
question I mean there's just some
operations where you have to let that's
what that's why I i gave the second tip
if you if you want if you know you're
going to group by a key ahead of time
and this key is going to fit on a note
when you read in the data already
partition it in such a way that it's
partitioned by that key such that no
shuffle has to happen
really helped performance a lot but the
others there is there some some
operational you can't avoid this but if
you do if you actually what you should
award is doing a group by key and then
reduce what you should run instead is
this tree reduced function because it
will compute intermediate results on the
under various workers and not put
everything in the second one node so we
also have some use cases would recruit
by key where we cannot avoid it right so
it depends really on what you want to do
thank you
thanks for your talk i sent a quick
question when you did encounter memory
issues how did you debug them how do we
do back them I mean though sometimes the
error messages they are very very non
informative is just what you do you know
google and look like over for I try to
figure things out I mean there's no yeah
i mean if you if you experience work
with the spy for a couple of months now
it's much easier now to understand the
problem but it's kind of difficult and
especially also when you do unit testing
as well so very handy tip is actually to
turn off the log in from from info to
error because then you don't get all
these things like like like what is the
petition which working machine isn't
like this so yeah and also for pi spark
actually unit testing can also be quite
difficult because of the communication
between PI for j so you get of lucky
from PI po j and then the the the error
message which is sent through private j
is quite useless and then there's also
the the web UI which is got a lot better
recently you can actually see the query
plan of your of your whatever you're
executing so you can monitor what what
what's going wrong yes
yes is there any cases when you use the
cast just the memory tends to recompute
everything nor we as also so I have an
encounter example where I said it to
memory only because that causes a lot of
problems if you said it to memory only
and the cluster runs out of memory it's
expel from memory but if you set it to
memory and disk if the cluster runs out
of memory it's serialized to disk at
least so it hasn't the rtd or data frame
doesn't have to be recomputed from
scratch at least it can read it from
disk and I haven't encountered an
example we're setting it to memory would
be a memory only would be of advantage
so so to get all the vital life and I
blew the circuit for machine learning is
there is it part of installed by along
with the cluster install order we have
to have a separate process to have all
the Python libraries as part of the
cluster what what we do is we install
anaconda on every single cluster node
and then set the Python path to anaconda
but on but but continuum has come out
with was actually a cluster management
service where you can do this much more
easily and push corner environments to
the cluster but it's a paid for servers
so so basically what you can do there's
some free open-source things like p as
its asian p SE p where you can also
dispute your thoughts on a different
manner different work machines is there
a way to just how Python library solely
for specific number of worker knows what
do you mean sure I understand you want
to only so far the back of the vital
night movies
want to only install them on a couple of
workers oh then you just just as if I
them in whatever whatever you're using
to push it to the environment you just
specify the host you would want to push
these two but there's no shortcut or
something we're very enough have you had
any experience of using the sword window
functions on the data frames like the
sequel window functions and other any
kind of similar traps when you're
grouping by their or no because at least
we haven't encountered any because it
did first of all it is able to use the
optimizer so instead of instead of
having to guess everything it's able to
actually produce a very smart execution
plan and usually we haven't encountered
any problems there yet yes apart from
better documentation what what more are
you hoping to see coming up from spark
in the future one thing is so maybe a
better more comprehensive online
learning learning libraries more focus
on generally the MLF library yeah and
also potentially that the Python API
doesn't lag behind slightly of as
compared to the Scala API at least as my
do you have any yeah I mean it's just
editing some point so like like the
machine learning library read their like
binary classification is much better in
scholar than in Python and it's already
implemented in scholar you just don't
see the function also in the
documentation there are some things
hidden that you don't see because they
just it's not sure not updated so right
worth way to read the apache spark
documentation the war version not the
use case the examples they give so
okay but we have actually no more time
but hey one more question more
clarification how do you generally store
your tour de chillon dispar for
performance porque ok actually be there
is this is a slide we had to take out
due to time if you actually want to use
you spar together with some sequel or a
dupe engines because mark sequel is not
so advanced it sometimes you instead
would want to use this sequel or a dupe
engine such as for example a hawk or and
pollen or something like this and you
can actually share data between these
using parque because porque contains the
metadata around the schema and so on so
that's very good it's also I've got
really really good compare performance
as compared to the other file formats
you tried all sorry about all as well
similar oak files or see obviously I
personally haven't we haven't tested or
see it but i assume yeah but but porque
porque is a fairly default format for
many applications running on top of
Hadoop now so you can interchange it
with many other applications I think
we're at that time thank you very much
thanks